my name is not important what is
important is what I'm going to do in
kindergarten no one would pick my
boogers I just [ __ ] hate this world
and the human world feasting on its
carcass
no one ever complimented me on how
friends [ __ ] tastic and shiny my
black Harris and I will put in a grave
as many as I can hatred the game looks
really cheesy I'm gonna it goes from
easy to hard for some reason just like
mom but it's supposed to be really
offensive I don't know why I did that
but I don't know I can't take [ __ ] like
this seriously all right this is me
bad bad bad bad press G to throw grenade
death row through here
holy [ __ ] all right Matthew
you must be crazy hey friends no one
appreciated my trench coat do you know
how much a [ __ ] spent on this it was
[ __ ] coolest [ __ ] in the matrix come
back here let's just pretend they're
zombies the [ __ ] are they driving in the
middle of the road everyone
there's lanes for a reason you idiots
you gonna get someone killed you're
dimwits I can do a little dances oh [ __ ]
thought it was dancing I'm sorry
that is execute someone with a [ __ ]
maid that's kind of awesome
oh my god you guys were watching one
tree here I love that show
why was I not invited my favorite David
Joe what's that did you say something
show me okay
what that's cute
was that it you don't barely touched him
like it out making my way downtown
walking fast faces pass them and
homebound
alright alright just a step just fine
say step
I'm beginning to feel like a cop cop cop
my people front row to the where am I
going
sorry it's so [ __ ] hard to see
because it's so dark
alright gotta sleep [ __ ] handled
words I won't have it anymore now Jesus
Christ I'm so nice people don't
appreciate me good night there we go
doing pretty well laughs oh damn that
was pretty sweet that was pretty awesome
you can't argue with that oh [ __ ] we're
closed tonight no I'm so close oh come
on
Oh what does
what is this what is going on ah come on
you kidding me all right suicide I can't
I don't want to risk start at the level
well it looks like I'm stuck
alright first I'll have to end that
episode there what do you think part of
me it's like it's just a video game
who gives a [ __ ] other part of me is
like it's done in a kind of tasteless
matter but the other part of me is like
but it's so stupid and the final part of
me is like what the [ __ ] is going up
there's another part of me thinks about
people who experience these kind of
shootings and and how they feel like if
they see a game like this I don't know
but that that's it for me
hope you enjoyed regardless this video
the guy could be dead and I'll see Bros
in the next one as always stay awesome
granny no I'm not gonna die here gray
it's silly now come on young live your
old and disgusting